[Aplausos]
[Música]
antes de empezar me gustaría preguntar o
saber si casi casi no se os ven pero era
para saber quién es aquí habéis oído
hablar de poli amor que levantéis la
mano por favor
eso lo que suele pasar que es como que
parece que se ha puesto de moda que es
como que se escucha en todas partes
hablar de poli amor sea en televisión
incluso com partidos políticos cuando
llega a un acuerdo pues está como este
es que están pensando en el poliamor no
parece como que es lo que parece que es
una moda lo que vengo a contaros yo es
que a lo mejor es algo más que una moda
esto es una búsqueda reciente que he
hecho de las búsquedas en google de la
palabra poliamor en nuestro país desde
y podéis ver como con altos y bajos pero
como va creciendo de manera sostenida y
de momento no tiene ninguna pinta de
querer bajar
podemos verlo en otros ámbitos también a
parte de nuestro país como por ejemplo
las publicaciones académicas desde desde
el año 2000 sobre el tema de poliamor en
todo el mundo y veis también el
crecimiento que tiene
o podéis ver en las citas académicas las
citas en trabajos académicos también
sobre poliamor como podéis ver es un
crecimiento exponencial
aquí en nuestro país nos puede parecer
una novedad pero la verdad es que en
eeuu por ejemplo desde hace más de 20
años o sea no hace dos días se ha ido
desarrollando toda una cultura que
incluye libros talleres terapeutas
congresos como el de la semana que viene
que hay en barcelona
se ha desarrollado toda toda una cultura
y que supone algo más que una moda todo
este tiempo que ha pasado lo suelo
describir más bien como un cambio de
mentalidad lo que se ha dado es algo
parecido suelo decir a cuando sucede
cuando apareció el divorcio cuando
apareció el divorcio de repente no se
divorció todo el mundo sino que se
divorció quien quería y quién podía en
ese momento y lo mismo ha pasado con el
poliamor y no monogamia en general ha
pasado lo mismo el que de repente ha ido
apareciendo otra alternativa que alguna
gente empieza a tener en cuenta
igual que como en el divorcio en la
monogamia pues depende de los miembros
de esa relación el que tenga una forma o
tenga u otra
pero
a menudo es como que el argumento este
que lo decidan los miembros de la
relación parece que como si no fuera
suficiente entonces parece que hay que
buscar más justificaciones y muy a
menudo se buscan justificaciones de que
es lo natural y entonces se dice por
ejemplo pues que en la prehistoria los
seres humanos es que eran más promiscuos
y por eso hoy día y que tal está tal o
que en otras culturas como el amor o por
ejemplo pues también es que tal hacen
las cosas de otra manera o por que los
bonobos como compartimos el 99% del adn
pues entonces también tenemos una buena
cantidad de parecidos con los bonobos
compartimos el 90% con los gatos y nadie
saca conclusiones
las comparaciones con animales son
efectistas pero son inútiles porque es
que es imposible que sepamos cómo se
comporta un ser humano en un estado
natural
todo ser humano va a crecer siempre
dentro de una cultura la que sea pero
siempre va a crecer dentro de uno
el concepto de natural es un poco
problemático como siempre cito a marcos
sanz
se le llama natural a lo que se le han
borrado las huellas de cómo ha sido
impuesto
cuando alguien te argumenta algo desde
lo natural normalmente es porque lo que
quiere es decirte que lo que te está
diciendo es que irrebatible
pero la verdad es que si fuera tan
natural la monogamia heterosexual por
ejemplo pues no habría tantísimas
infidelidades como se han ido
documentando desde los años 50 con 15 y
ni se habría perseguido con tanto empeño
a hombres que tienen relaciones con
hombres mujeres con mujeres o aun
mujeres adúlteras con el doble rasero
que ya conocemos
como digo no hace falta irse a esta
argumentación de que es lo natural sino
que simplemente deriva de algo
suficientemente complejo que es el
el deseo es ese origen tan complicado de
nuestras fantasías de nuestros deseos de
quien nos atrae y quien no nos atrae
todo eso ya suficientemente complejo y
eso es lo que nos acaba llevando a
decidir pues algunas personas a tener
una relación exclusiva y entonces pues
no tienen relaciones sexuales ni
afectivas con nadie más fuera de esa
pareja hay quienes deciden abrirlo las
relaciones sexuales y tenerlas con más
gente
reservarse digamos la parte afectiva
como suele pasar en el ambiente swinger
y pasa también la otra opción el que se
abra la opción tanto para relaciones
afectivas como sexuales en el caso del
poliamor y no monogamia en general
gracias al
a los medios de comunicación gracias a
las series de televisión que también hay
un montón y gracias al trabajo del
activismo pues hay un montón de libros
de talleres de recursos de información
para que podamos decidir el tipo de
relación que queremos tener
una cosa es la teoría y otra cosa muy
diferente es la práctica
pero esta teoría nos la sabemos todo el
mundo la teoría poli amorosa es muy
fácil de aprender se la de memoria de
soltarla para ligar es muy efectiva pero
la práctica es muy distinta a la
práctica a la gente se la suele tomar
como si fuera una app como una
aplicación del móvil y es como esperas
que he oído hablar de paul y amor le voy
a descargar se descargan la aplicación
la instalan mete sus datos la arrancan a
fundir para que se ponga a funcionar
descubren lo más habitual es que
descubras que no funciona
porque pues yo suelo achacar a menudo el
problema está en lo que le llamo yo
sistema operativo sistema operativo de
cada cual viene a ser una metáfora por
la biografía de cada cual de la vida que
hemos tenido el cómo te han criado en
los dos primeros años de tu vida tienen
una importancia fundamental en cómo te
relacionas con otra gente pero tus
experiencias anteriores en otras
relaciones también influyen mucho el que
te hayan educado como hombre como mujer
el que pertenezca a algún grupo
discriminado el que sus circunstancias
personales simplemente todo eso puede
influir en que funcione o no funcione y
lo más común lo tienes osaka vice
atreviendo hacerlo
os encontraréis que te acabas
encontrando en una tierra de nadie entre
está medido entre seis meses y dos años
y
durante ese tiempo estás despistado ahí
tienes el despiste de no saber qué hacer
porque no te funciona ni la monogamia ni
la no monogamia y es en ese tiempo lo
que estás haciendo es adaptando todo ese
lío de ideas que has oído sobre
monogamia y no monogamia a tu propia
vida lo que estás haciendo es como
adaptándolo
las circunstancias en las que te
encuentras no es pasar de ave no es
pasar de una relación de una de dos
personas a tres sino es de dos a hacer
las cosas de otra manera lo que es un
lío soberano
y entonces si es un lío porque la gente
se mete en ese lío que me he ido
encontrando yo con el camino las razones
para meterse en ese lío hay desde
quienes se meten porque tienen más
relaciones sexuales porque dicen
simplemente me voy a relacionar con más
gente tendré más relaciones sexuales hay
quien lo hace por tener más relaciones
románticas y lo mismo el disfrutar de
estarse enamorando de esta persona y de
la otra y de la otra hay quienes lo
hacen porque vienen de una crisis de
pareja y en ese caso yo no lo
recomendaría pero ya cada cual pero si
te sale mal con dos igual mal con tres
igual va un poco peor
hay quien lo hace por construir las
relaciones de otra manera también es
común escuchar a quienes lo construyen
como idea para construir una red de
cuidados y también como desde una
motivación política que hay que tener
cierto cuidado con la motivación
política porque no todo el mundo tiene
una conciencia política al mismo momento
que la tienes tú y ya venimos de muchos
modelos impuestos como para venir a
imponer otro modelo yo prefiero dar algo
de perspectiva y que sea esa persona a
la que elige qué tipo de relación quiere
tener
aún así eso yo advertencia atrás atrás
advertencia
igual los ahorros algún disgusto también
diciendo cuáles son los errores más
comunes al meterse en este lío el
primero más común es el de abrir la
relación con la palabra abrir y nadie se
para ni un momento a pensar qué quiere
decir abrir quiere decir que puedes
estar con colegas de trabajo que puedes
estar con alguien de tu familia con
alguien muy joven con alguien muy mayor
con prácticas sexuales no convencionales
abril quiere decir que la convivencia se
contempla como algo posible en ese
futuro o que haya descendencia que
también puede suceder y en esos casos lo
que recomiendo es sentarse y ponerse a
centrarlo un poco para saber si se
quiere abrir solo las relaciones
sexuales a lo mejor o si también se
quiere abrir en lo afectivo y en qué
grado y encontrar un punto en el que se
acabe llegando un acuerdo que satisfaga
a todo el mundo
si se cuenta o no se cuenta también hay
quienes prefieren no saber nada y
quienes prefieren saberlo todo y quienes
ni todo ni nada sino solo lo importante
pero no demasiado el tener unas reglas
de partida hay quienes prefieren tener
unas reglas muy fijas y quienes
prefieren ir negociando sobre la marcha
y está la opción también de las de saber
de pensar sobre si la libertad es lo más
importante en esa relación o sí
el cuidado mutuo equilibra un poco esa
idea de libertad
la cuestión es cómo ir encontrando un
punto en el que estén de acuerdo porque
ese es el segundo error más común el de
no llegar a este acuerdo desde la
complicidad sino que hay veces que se
dice bueno pues vale abrimos la relación
y cada cual va por un lado y no parte
desde un plan común desde ser cómplices
en ese proyecto
y quizá deciden pues no nos contamos
nada o igual deciden nos contamos poco
decidan lo que decidan todo lo que salga
desde la complicidad va a unir todo lo
que nos salga desde ahí va a distanciar
y el tercer error más común es el liarse
con los tipos de relación que se quiere
tener que si quiero tener poliamor
jerárquico no jerárquico
la realidad de los tipos de relación se
parece más a esto
ya sabéis el tipo no os habéis situado
en el tipo de relación que queréis
no está bien claro este sale de la web
more than puntocom y es eso el autor
pues eso lo que hace es como poner todos
los tipos que hay de relaciones posibles
yo lo suelo utilizar para explicar no
hay unos límites nítidos entre unos
tipos de relación y otros sino que hay
veces que puede haber dos personas que
pueden tener una relación muy ética y
muy libre y puede haber una relación
poli amorosa en la que haya muy poco
espacio para el cuidado mutuo o para el
crecimiento personal
y aún así si lo tienes claro
y te quieres meter puedes encontrarte
que tampoco es para ti y te puedes
encontrar con la analogía que suelo
hacer con el running qué
pues ves a todo el mundo que está
haciéndolo igual para ti no es igual
para ti te viene bien y la natación pero
no ir a correr el saber qué teoría y
práctica van a ser muy diferentes que
tienes que ir poco a poco y sobre todo
ser consciente que lo que vas a hacer es
un cambio radical en la manera de
establecer relaciones por primera vez lo
que se está haciendo es tener relaciones
donde lo importante ya deja de ser con
quien compartes la gama sino que se abre
el abanico a que pueda haber más
relaciones a que esas relaciones puedan
ir evolucionando y eso implica
consecuencias en legislación en
consecuencias en un montón de ámbitos de
la vida que pueden sonar un poco utópico
la ley de economía común en portugal
cubre eso desde el año 2001 o sea que
igual llegamos un poco por detrás
momento en el que estamos viviendo es en
el que se está haciendo visible una
diversidad que no se ha visto nunca
antes o sea no se ha visto con esta
variedad esta variedad se vio en los
años 20 y fue arrasada por los fascismos
y por la segunda guerra mundial en los
años 70 con la revolución sexual también
se vio un poco se vio como cierta
expectativa pero es ahora el momento en
el que si se están dando un montón de
alternativas que hubieran hecho la vida
muchísimo más fácil a millones de
personas que han sido perseguidas por
vivir su identidad sexual o sus
relaciones sexuales o sus relaciones
personales de otra manera y ahora es el
momento en el que tenemos la posibilidad
con un voto o con apoyando proyectos
locales por ejemplo seguro que en
alcohol hay personas interesadas en
arrancar proyectos de ese tipo grupos
activistas hay un montón de redes y de
activistas que están deseando tener un
apoyo para que se haga visible una
diversidad que ya existe que está aquí
que está todo el tiempo y lo único que
necesita es medios y espacios para
desarrollarse y crecer
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]